the bbc issued a rare public apology to
the royals over this bombshell 1995
princess diana interview well there were
three of us in this marriage so it was a
bit crowded
a statement was read in court saying
they quote apologized to the prince of
wales and to the dukes of cambridge and
sussex for the way in which princess
diana was deceived i've interviewed the
princess of wales so if anybody's guilty
of intrusion and access then it's
somebody like me last year a judge ruled
journalist martin beshear used deceitful
methods to gain access to princess diana
including forging documents martin asked
me
to make up
a couple of bank statements another
alleged tactic creating a false story
william and harry's former nanny
alexandra pettifer had an affair with
prince charles and an abortion
sorry
the bbc says they will now pay pettifer
substantial damages had we done our job
properly princess diana would have known
the truth during her lifetime the bbc's
failures contributed significantly to
her fear
paranoia and isolation there's no better
way to dismantle her personality than to
isolate it as for bashir the disgraced
journalist was last seen in february
having dinner with alec baldwin he
maintains the interview did not cause
princess diana any harm she really
wanted to say her piece and in a way i
was lucky because i was the person that
she told it to
[Music]